non-minimalists
you had this beautiful moment of of true
expression and it's what our friend
colin wright calls the i'll tell you
policy
like he has a great book called uh some
thoughts about relationships
it's it's not just my favorite colin
book but it's my
favorite book about relationships period
these little pithy sort of policies that
he has
about any relationship that he enters
into uh intimate or otherwise
and one is the i'll tell you policy
that's the one that i've used most in my
current relationship
to make it thrive in fact when
something's not going well
bex will come to me and say well you
didn't honor the i'll tell you policy
that's good and that kind of
accountability for it to hold each other
accountable for that in fact she did
this with me just
the other day and and it can it's it's
usually with small stuff
because you even with the small things
those things can fester and then
resentment builds right
for not being completely forthright and
what you had was this three-hour
i'll tell you like like
battle and battle royal right of of like
here's a lot of things that
we haven't maybe stuck to the full i'll
tell you up until this point because
she had one foot out for six months yeah
and
and for whatever reason maybe she felt
like she couldn't talk to you about it
maybe she felt like you weren't
providing the space for her
to talk about it uh maybe she just
wasn't ready to talk about it but
sometimes
before we're even ready we need to it
doesn't mean we just need to
vomit up every little thought that we
have
in fact that can be detrimental but if
something is going on we usually know
but the nice thing about that is bex and
i very rarely go to each other now say
is everything okay oh yeah no because
that happens
all the time in other relationships that
i've had you sure everything's okay like
i can see it on your features you're
hiding something
uh and and maybe you're wanting me to
ask you that question so you can open it
up
you don't have to wait for me to say is
everything okay to tell me what's what's
going on i feel like at that point if
you're if you're consistently asking
your partner like is everything okay
you're sure
like there is a a deeper thing that's
happening there where you you you don't
have good communication
right like if you're always wondering
and worrying what the other person is
feeling
thinking and you read into every uh
single situation or facial expression or
lack of comment or whatever yeah i feel
like you're in a position where
um you need to have that couple hour
long conversation on the couch and say
like where
where are we at and like here's what i
promised to do uh for you and for myself
which is to always be honest and direct
to tell you how i'm feeling when it
when i feel it it's appropriate yeah and
that that communication
it can be an error on both sides meaning
um yes like there's obviously a
communicationer some
uh partner isn't my partner isn't
willing to tell me what's wrong
but also someone who asked that question
a lot there might be something wrong
with themselves like
they might be uh themselves holding back
some
information